digamos que tenemos un sub espacio
vectorial b y vamos a dibujarlo como si
fuera un plano es decir tenemos aquí un
sub espacio vectorial b que más o menos
es de esta forma vamos a hacerlo un
poquito distinto
y está ok vamos a hacerlo derecho más o
menos este es nuestro sub espacio
vectorial ve ok
este es nuestro sub espacio de d sub
espacio y vamos a suponer que tengo un
vector x digamos un vector x cualquiera
por aquí que éste es director x lo que
quiero hacer o lo que quiero mostrar en
este vídeo es que la proyección de x
sobre el sub espacio sobre nuestro sub
espacio b es el vector más cercano que
podemos encontrar dentro del psuv
espacio y es más cercano a x verdad
entonces aquí estaremos pensando que la
proyección de x sobre nuestro sub
espacio pues es un vector por aquí ok es
más o menos este vector
de aquí
a este punto entonces aquí estamos
pensando que está el origen y este este
de aquí es la proyección la proyección
sobre el espacio ve del vector x muy
bien entonces aquí lo que vamos a
demostrar es utilizando fórmulas de
distancia es verdad porque lo que
tenemos lo que tenemos es lo siguiente
yo lo que yo quiero calcular la
distancia de x a éste a este vector que
es la proyección sobre el espacio b
entonces si nos tomamos por ejemplo
cualquier otro vector que se encuentre
en nuestro sub espacio digamos este
vector de aquí vamos a llamarle b ok
este vector de aquí lo que yo tengo que
demostrar es que la distancia de x a la
proyección sobre el sub espacio b de ese
x y que de hecho la distancia está dado
a sí verdad como la la norma o la
magnitud de la diferencia de estos dos
vectores ya que eso me da la distancia
que hay
entre estos dos puntos entonces lo que a
mí me gustaría ver es que si este vector
que es la resta vamos a poner este que
es la resta en este de aquí
este de aquí es la resta a muy bien
entonces
este esta diferencia la distancia debe
superar debe ser perdón debe ser menor
al revés verdad debe ser mucho menor que
esta otra distancia que tuviéramos por
aquí
es decir si fuéramos de equis a
cualquier otro vector b ok entonces esto
debe ser mucho menor debe ser menor o
igual no necesariamente mucho verdad a
lo mejor están aquí cerquita pero debe
ser menor o igual que la distancia entre
x y b es decir lo podemos escribir como
la norma por la magnitud de la
diferencia verdad x menos b entonces
este vector de aquí es x menos b y
estamos vamos a demostrar que esta
desigualdad es cierta y para hacer eso
lo que vamos a hacer es ir construyendo
algunos otros vectores que nos vayan a
ir auxiliando vamos a partir de esta de
esta norma partamos de la norma de x
menos b y vamos a hacer esto al cuadrado
ok vamos a partir con eso al cuadrado
esto quién es esto esencialmente lo
podemos ver de la siguiente forma
podemos construir un vector que vaya de
aquí
a este punto y que vamos a llamar be ok
y luego si le sumamos a entonces estamos
partiendo de este punto y llegamos a x
entonces x b lo podemos expresar como la
norma la norma de masa donde esté aquí
esta vez de este color b más a más a que
está en verde verdad este de aquí este
de aquí es a
entonces estamos calculando esta norma
ahora bien quienes ve quienes ven pues
esencialmente ve no es otra cosa más que
la proyección de x este vector menos b
verdad porque es el que apunta debe a la
proyección entonces esto es igual esto
es igual a la proyección a la a la
proyección
la proyección sobre ve del vector x
menos ve - el vector be ok entonces
estévez es el que apunta debe bueno de
vela vial be de burro es el que apunta
debe de vaca
la proyección entonces es la diferencia
de esos dos vectores muy bien entonces
es esta diferencia y como estamos
elevando al cuadrado lo ponemos al
cuadrado y por qué lo hicimos al
cuadrado porque al cuadrado lo podemos
expresar como un producto punto entonces
esto será de masa punto de masa de más a
muy bien y esto sí si utilizamos las
propiedades distributivas del producto
punto no es otra cosa más que de punto b
a punto b y luego seguiría de punto
entonces tenemos dos veces a punto b más
apuntó
ahora hay que notar algo que es muy
importante donde se encuentra nuestro
vector b si nos damos cuenta es la
diferencia de dos vectores que se
encuentran en nuestro psuv espacio
entonces b se encuentra en nuestro psuv
espacio y por otro lado a es un vector
que construimos por definición que sea
ortogonal a todo el espacio verdad
entonces en particular va a ser
ortogonal a b quiere decir que esto que
tenemos aquí no es otra cosa más que 0
eso se anula no le queda de otra más que
ser anulado entonces esto ya nos da
muchísima muchísima herramienta para
seguir trabajando y ver qué es lo que
está ocurriendo porque la diferencia
está esta norma la norma de x menos b al
cuadrado como éste terminó en cero no
nos queda b punto b que es la norma debe
al cuadrado
la norma de al cuadrado la norma de a al
cuadrado sin embargo hay que notar que
como la norma debe es al cuadrado es un
número positivo o podría ser cero pero
pero al menos es cero o algo más grande
que cero entonces esto necesariamente es
mayor o igual que la norma de a al
cuadrado podría ser igual si la norma
debe cero pero en general no
necesariamente tiene que ser así puede
ser cualquier otro vector pero su norma
al cuadrado es un número positivo
entonces si a un número le le le sumas
algo positivo pues definitivamente va a
ser más grande que el número original
entonces lo que tenemos es que la norma
de x menos b al cuadrado es mayor o
igual que la norma de a al cuadrado sin
embargo hay que bueno podríamos sacar
raíz cuadrada de ambos lados y tenemos
que la norma de x menos b al cuadrado es
mayor verdad
dijimos que íbamos a quitar este
cuadrado sacamos raíz cuadrada de ambos
lados de la desigualdad y nos queda que
la norma de x menos b es mayor o igual
que la norma de a muy bien entonces esto
simplemente lo reescribimos porque a
quienes es x menos la proyección de b
entonces este resultado de aquí lo
podemos expresar de la siguiente forma
que la norma de x b es mayor o igual que
la norma de a pero a es x menos la
proyección sobre el vector de de x y
esto por supuesto fue un resultado
general es decir nos tomamos un b
arbitrario nuestro psuv espacio y como
fue arbitrario entonces esto se vale
para cualquier punto que se encuentre en
el sub espacio cualquier punto que se
encuentra en el sub espacio su distancia
x va a ser siempre mayor o igual que la
distancia de x a la proyección y por lo
tanto la más corta de todas las project
es la más corta de todas las distancias
es la de la proyección sobre nuestro sub
espacio y ahí lo tienen hemos demostrado
esta propiedad y esto pasa también para
cualquier vector arbitrario x que se
encuentre en nuestro espacio